[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance
another day another Trump pivot that
wasn't American political media unable
to shake itself of the narrow walls
within which it is operated for decades
unable to think not just outside the box
but to even believe that there is
anything outside the box has been
telling us since the day he announced
his candidacy to take over the
government that Trump is changing wrong
again
they use only about 50 terms but they
blurt them usually in spasms of
certitude again and again and now in
three different calendar years Trump is
changing moving to the center getting
realistic being pragmatic becoming a
real candidate broadening his base
guiding the convention back to the
middle toning it down for the debates
appealing to the undecideds blunting the
edge of his rhetoric transitioning to
his left
preparing to unite his party preparing
to unite left and right preparing to
unite the nation about to go PI partisan
sure to speak presidential II in his
inaugural address guaranteed to reel
himself in certainly to defer to his
advisors going to be guided by Ryan and
McConnell planning to work with his
party planning to work with his cabinet
planning to work with the Democrats
deferring to the generals planning to
drop the angry rhetoric looking for a
more centrist path crafting a speech to
unify the nation becoming presidential
tomorrow becoming presidential today
becoming presidential tonight became
presidential tonight
became presidential yesterday will
certainly become presidential and stay
presidential next time nope we could go
back to Van Jones declaring that when
Trump honored the widow of the Navy SEAL
during his pseudo State of the Union
address quote he became President of the
United States in that moment period and
quote for people who have been hoping
that maybe he would remain a divisive
cartoon they should be a little bit
worried tonight yeah he remained a
divisive cartoon we could go back to
that moment but that was February
frickin 28th and we only need to go back
to last week to see how gullible most of
the American political media real
is Trump made his desperate you like me
you really like me Sally Field debt deal
with the Democrats Friday and out rolled
the pivot stories on Saturday 11:32 a.m.
Saturday Washington Post standard-issue
political guy quote in spirit President
Trump isn't a Democrat or a Republican
he's a freewheeling transactional Paul
who looks for wins no isn't he's just
crazy 12:30 1:00 p.m. Saturday
Associated Press standard-issue
political reporters Trump the
independent the deal president Trump cut
with Democrats seems to show a different
kind of president no it doesn't he's
just crazy to 24 p.m. Saturday New York
Times standard-issue political guy
tweeting an article itself headlined
bound to no party Trump up ends 150
years of two-party rule and adds I'm The
Lone Ranger in some ways Trump is the
first independent to serve as president
in modern times no he's not he's just
crazy I'm gonna crib something from the
book that I think explains both the
reason this keeps happening
Trump leaps into the air or trips over
himself or steps on a rake or steps back
to admire his work and plummets off the
scaffolding or just falls flat on his
face and the media says ooh look a pivot
and why it is so important and so
damaging to dealing with the reality of
our current American predicament the
thing that seemed to be sustaining Trump
was the media's continuing refusal to
acknowledge that what the rest of us
were all seeing and what they were
pretending wasn't happening was
something that was outside their
collective experience I spent 20 years
just in sports news and then 20 years
mostly just in political news and it
never ceased to amaze me that sports
reporters were constantly expecting even
hoping to cover things that had never
happened before
meanwhile their political counterparts
seem to have been entirely constructed
out of the conviction that nothing that
had
happened before in American history
could possibly happen now there couldn't
be a candidate who sold his soul to
another country to get elected because
they had never covered one before there
couldn't be a semi-functioning disturbed
psyche occupying the White House because
they had never run into one in the
Senate or the house or whatever County
Board they broke in covering and they
certainly couldn't write any of these
things because Bill Sapphire Tom wicker
Christopher Hitchens Merriman Smith or
whoever else they secretly thought they
were had never written such things so
onwards they marched surprised by every
rake they stepped on awaking each
morning fully convinced things would get
back to normal and they could rework
something they had written in 1999
unwilling to invoke the words treason or
madness because they weren't legal or
psychological experts as if you needed
to be an electrical engineer to write
about how the wiring had just caught
fire so next time you read about the new
Trump or the independent Trump or the
true Trump the Trump you love the Trump
you knew the Trump with a song in his
heart
remember this is because the guy writing
the article literally cannot imagine
that this whole unprecedented disaster
isn't just going to go back to being
normal all by itself and the writer also
cannot imagine that everything won't
return to that place where he and
writers like him can function without
thinking and at the moment be-all does
go back to being one of only three or
four kinds of presidents we've ever had
before he's the one who's gonna get that
scooped first it's simple no Trump is
not pivoting he's just crazy resist
remove peace